moment c'est un deux salles deux
ambiances est un obstacle ces gens
messias son compte twitter ces questions
sur et jean médecin vous devez donner
votre avis il ya un instant on va voir
ce qu'en pensent les téléspectateurs
après vous pouvez en parler à une
personne de twitter normal ça fait pour
42% voilà c'est diviser mais c'est plus
du côté de normal la normalité sinon
alors vous avez c'est que vous avez
c'est le contact et twitter pour leur
poser une question tarifs et j'envoyais
des dizaines et des dizaines d'appels et
ça aussi ça pose problème parce que
quand encore une fois quand on a dans
n'importe quel domaine vous avez des
médiateurs quand vous avez un problème
avec votre banque vous avez un médiateur
pose un problème avec l'administration
vous avez quelqu'un qui parlait quand
vous êtes viré d'une boîte on vous dit
pourquoi et bien là vous pouvez le
twitter peu comme ça couper le sifflet à
quelqu'un qui a un qui parle
publiquement à 165 mille personnes moi
je crois que quand on interdit à un
homme public d'avoir une parole publique
puisque un réseau social c'est un réseau
public c'est un acte politique c'est pas
c'est pas un acte technique vous rigolez
nicolas pernikoff parce que c'est
toujours la même chose et on se fait un
nom mais il essaie de se faire passer
pour une victime donc ça me fait rigoler
parce que
bien sûr qu'il va les regretter renom
qui ont france aiea les bois garde à gré
et ce toutes les haines est ce qu'on a
le droit d'écrire ça on en attend d'elle
alors l'incitation à la haine c'est une
qualification juridique c'est pas
n'importe qui sortent en n'importe où
avec ses liens qui vous aimez un pont
soit là je pense que c'est une bonne
chose et vous ont dit qu'ils vont vous
remettre votre compte ou pas non mais
moi vous savez tous les deux le 10
septembre sur l'anniversaire ah oui les
10 septembre tous les nids séparant le
10 septembre pour ceux qui connaissent
pas twitter quand on va vous le jour de
votre anniversaire quand vous ouvrez la
page twitter de ballons
oui dix ans je les voyais j'aimerais
bien les voir cette année
on va cueillir
on va accueillir tous y être car là donc
de twitter alors apparemment il est
responsable communication de p te
remercie michel
[Applaudissements]
michel merci d'être là vous êtes
si twitter
[Rires]
4 pas de rigoler 8 où je suis directeur
de la communication europe pour twitter
retrouver excusez-moi espère retrouver
son groupe michel cardin bah écoutez
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que voilà il
ya des commissions qui sera une essence
chez twitter europe pour les
réactivations de compte donc il ya eu
cinq réunions déjà existants vous avez
des réunions concernant jean bessière
c'est pourquoi j'ai pas de réponse à
tout mais randonnée rien commission qui
se tient le temps on va décider votants
vous avez tous les réseaux sociaux comme
ça je pleure youtube vous faites une
plainte et à vous avez quelqu'un en
personne qui vous répond ainsi vous
réponds personnellement si vous dis
voilà votre demande est traitée par
intel vous pouvez le contacter si vous
avez des questions enfin c'est juste en
fait vous êtes directeur de la
communication mais vous communiquez avec
qui vous communiquer quoi passé moi
l'expression c'est juste une question
froid des cloisons que je crois
alors vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que
votre compte elle a enfreint plusieurs
règles morales donc ça vous l'avez
rappelé mois la voilà sur différents ave
165 mille abonnés il avait 150 abonnés
dont je pense 120000 voilà qui sont les
voilà qu'ils sont cons ont été achetés
en chine non vraiment
non
[Musique]
ça c'est de la diffamation
entre vingt et une vingtaine trentaine
de compte
quelques-uns qui s'abonnent à vous
sentir un peu passé on peut pas le
savoir moi j'ai jamais à changer jamais
acheté aucun abonné sûr on aurait pu
certainement parce que c'est celui-là me
plaît jeandebon gens non mais c'est une
fausse information je tiens à le dire un
stand fait que news alors est-ce que
vous allez leur acte qui veut son compte
un jour ou si vraiment on réactivera
jamais votre compte
je crois qu attendez vous contredisez il
ya un instant vous disiez qu'il y avait
des commissions qui se réunissent pour
célébrer les cinq fois et qui ont tout
fait pour les personnes importantes
n'ont pas faire il a fait mais quand
mais j'ai une question importante mais
comment qui a pris cette décision
d'arrêter son d'arrêter son compte et ça
que j'aimerais savoir comment ça s'est
passé c'est philippe pathoux la cchit
bien
quand vous le disais tout à l'heure il
ya déjà eu un rappel voilà monsieur
delormeau la deûle a rappelé tout à
l'heure voilà il a eu un rappel on vous
a prévenu et comme voilà dans toute
entreprise il ya eu un rappel les choses
ce sont les tweets ont continué sur le
même thème et du coup on est vous ayez
l'impression que la politique en fait
parce que j'ai déjà cité le cas d'autres
exemples qu'ils sont eux au qui ont eux
été condamnés par la loi donc c'est pas
simplement une vue de l'esprit de
twitter qui décide qui moralement à tort
michel vous avez des porte-parole de
mouvements terroristes
ne sont pas censurés juste mais chaque
arme à ce que vous allez vous soutenir
mais non on ne reverra jamais son compte
j'arrive
non mais oh ça
[Rires]
ces ballons d'essai dans la lucarne
opposée n'aurait pas dû à londres voilà
moi c'est michel carnage que vous allez
réactiver son compte non
[Applaudissements]
mais méchaal tard est-ce que vous allez
une dernière chose à dire à jean
bessière a
écouté non voilà pas de ballons cette
année
résultat
merci
c'est michel dit merci michel carrade
est devenu le meilleur garçon
tring dernière chose non non non merci
ont invité merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les cas joe pas lui c'est michel candat
ce ténor max
narbonne
[Musique]
ces frissons et non mais je me suis
douté il y avait des commissions qui
seront réunis à l'aube encore statut
après on le rendra jamais non mais est
tombé à l'eau il admet enfin iliad est
coté à mougins pour saccager en tout cas
on en a parlé lors il faut aussi et
peut-être que ça à faire bouger toute
façon donc on va voir et en tout cas
vous la voulez donner votre avis merci
je rends au bourbier de talent on pas
jamais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
d'accord merci jean michel dhalenne dos
nu voilà merci d'abord merci
m